all the years
this channel has existed no matter where
i have
lived that same noise following me
around and
all these videos all my homes
what if it's the same gardener it's the
same gardener stalking you
[Music]
max katie is here messing up all the
videos get a copyright claim for that
he's a spy from tyrone how's your
tuesday going guys
spider-man no way home all proof of toby
maguire and andrew garfield
spider-verse i need this after
andrew garfield's i'm not the winner oh
no
you just i just got to prove i'm not him
and everybody thinks i'm him
with beetles
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk
all things marvel and of course
spider-man no
way home the first film that has yet to
be confirmed to be a spider-man film by
marvel studios and sony but has pretty
much been confirmed by
i think it's a spider-man film i think
it means spider-verse
yes it's okay we're all send rumors and
reports
and instagram posts of stunt doubles
tagging other stunt doubles and there's
just been so much going on i'm going to
break down
every important thing that we've heard
about spiderman no way home
so far and reminder about my
stormbreaker giveaway it ends at the end
of this month so be sure to check out
the description and pin comment for
details on how to enter
so in this video we're going to go over
14 different things that you
need to know about the upcoming
spider-man no way home film each of
these points are very important topics
that have come out about the movie
over the past year or so my buddy chris
over at cosmic culture originally did a
video on this
shout out to him he's done a great job
let's dive into it
number one the president of marvel
studios kevin feige said himself
that this film no way home is going to
connect to doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness it's going to lead
up to it
with that confirmation that benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange will indeed
be in spiderman no way home now why is
he in spiderman no way home there are a
lot of other heroes that could help
peter out that are in new york
and the answer is doctor strange knows
how to deal with
the multiverse so right away multiverse
being in spider-man away home is a
pretty big
sign that the spider-verse is also going
to be in no way home it's called
multiverse of madness
you got doctor strange gonna be in the
spider-man movie
it just it's just it's it's it's yeah
yes
solid point number one thank you warren
point number two
and this is kind of like the biggest
deal to me because it's
a personal experience and that is i got
copy striked
not copyright claimed copy striked it's
a big deal
by the latin america sony group and the
video that they copy straight should we
take
our
that sony latin america put out that
talked about seeing
all three spider verses in one film it
started off by asking who your favorite
spider-man was and then it went on to
say that all three of them are going to
appear in the same film
and they were specifically talking about
spider-man no way home they talked about
seeing the movie on christmas
of 2021 the release date for no way home
now obviously this video was not
supposed to go out it was quickly
removed after but i posted it and they
took it down and when spiderman
far few came out they released multiple
trailers in multiple tv spots in which i
posted them all
doing breakdowns and showing clips they
never claimed a single one of them
so why would they claim this video well
it's probably because it revealed the
spider-verse and that is something they
do not want shown
so to me that's really the big one a lot
of proof to me
the third point that is like major
absolutely they don't want they
literally
stopped you spreading that word i
remember when we covered that
we should private right this minute
so that there's a record of it a lot of
times reaction channels will work
together like that
yeah we're doing a copyright strike you
gotta take that video down we haven't
been touched by them yet but he said
sony gave him the copyright that's right
that's the fish that's as official as it
gets and that trailer was talking about
spider-man three coming out in christmas
seeing all the spider-man together i
thought it was like maybe there's a
chance it might have been a leaked
video maybe it was a family who knows
but if
sony directly is giving you a copyright
strike saying
it's not this wasn't supposed to happen
oh damn that is
nuts i'm sorry yeah
you're you're sacrificing what yeah
sacrifices
as much evidence as we need the third
point is the recent andrew garfield
interviews
you know the ones where he claims that
he's not the werewolf or he's not the
mafia
to be frank i think it's a really cool
idea in these interviews he
kind of denies that he's going to be in
no way home but he never actually says
he's not in the film he talks about the
game werewolf and mafia where the whole
point is to convince people that you're
not the werewolf and you're not the
mafia
he states he feels like he's playing the
game and he's telling everybody hey
i'm not the werewolf can you not say the
l one if you're the werewolf
is to convince people you're not the
werewolf so he's literally saying
i'm not the werewolf meaning i'm not i'm
really distracted by here
i know because it's too convincing how
many times has the word shown up
so it really seems like he's in the
movie and he's just trying to convince
people that he's not in the movie he
also had this pretty well rehearsed
story about the werewolf and the mafia
that he seemed to tell in each interview
but
then out of nowhere in another interview
he said
never say never he dropped the whole
story and when he was asked about ever
appearing with the other two spider-man
he said never say never so i already
didn't believe him in the first two
interviews but then he turned around and
completely changed the story
then he got the call i mean but if you
say never say never when the movie's
already done
filming you know it's not like hey you
know they might ask me to be in it now
it reshoots me like we say never say
never
it's either you're in it or you're not
in it at this point yeah you can't just
leave the door open for you to be in it
when they're done filming the movies
so uh yeah i don't know it seems like he
is glaringly not denying this either way
then we have point number four going
over to another spider-man toby maguire
right when the filming for spider-man no
way home was starting the paparazzi
snagged a lot of pictures of toby
maguire going to a costume fitting
and here's the deal toby maguire doesn't
have any upcoming movies he was
rumored to be playing a character in
babylon but that is yet to be confirmed
so really the only movie that he could
be getting
fitted for is spider-man no way home now
he was spotted before filming and then
he was spotted after filming and
after filming he looked a lot better
than he did before
he was clean-shaven oh you're looking
good and this is most likely due to him
playing his old role of peter parker
no obviously he doesn't do all of the
stunts but he doesn't just sit there and
do nothing so that would explain why he
is all of a sudden
in much better shape and since we're
talking about actors for no way home
that comes up i can believe it
molina this dude basically confirmed the
spider-verse
i mean he actually did confirm it in the
interview he talked about
how he asked director john watts how his
character is going to all of a sudden be
alive when the last time we saw him he
was dead
in which he told us that the director
said in this universe nobody really dies
and he also revealed that they're going
to take his character from that very
final moment right before he dies and
that's where we're going to pick off
with the character
so right at this moment he's going to be
taken away from the sam
raymond universe right before he dies
and brought into the marvel
cinematographers
from one spider-man universe to another
if that is not confirming the
spider-verse i don't really know what
else is
except for you know marvel coming out
and stating that hey it's a spider verse
hopefully that happens soon but in the
meantime let's continue on with point
number six
i mean look what alfred man that just
gets louder and louder
alfred molina yeah he's uh i'm warren's
100
right if you've read it he's confirming
the spider verse exists yeah
i mean at that point if it was a joke i
feel like marvel
would have stepped in and done something
about it he's saying he's playing the
same character how is my character still
alive
he literally is answering and he's in
the tom hall in the movie
yeah yeah it's a spider verse and this
interview is like
no one asked and then here's just all
these details sticking with actor
confirmations point number six is jamie
foxx jamie foxx will be returning in no
way home
as elektra which he played in the
amazing spider-man universe
after one of the trade companies
reported that jamie foxx would be
returning as elektro in no way home
jamie foxx posted on his instagram also
confirming that he is indeed coming
however he did delete the post
not too long afterwards
[Music]
because marvel studios tells them hey
you weren't supposed to put that take
that off
it's usually a pretty good sign point
number seven is
jj j jonah jameson of the daily bugle
all of a sudden he is back and he's in
the mcu and of course he is still being
played by jk simmons
i get bringing jjj into the mcu because
we haven't seen him yet but why
use the same actor why use the actor
from the raimi universe if
some type of spider-verse wasn't
involved so because he's the best actor
for the role yeah
it's too perfect from the same universe
the raymond universe is coming back as
well
and a ton of reports stating that willem
dafoe's green goblin is coming back too
so really that's just another
confirmation that this movie is going to
be a spider-verse film
i mean in all fairness i feel like with
jk simmons
it could just be he's the best one cast
for the role and it's like a fan
nod because they mixed up the look and
the general output of the bugle and all
that yeah because what's the
what are the chances that jay jonah
jameson is from the raimi verse
comes over in the tom holland world and
is like perfect
i'm going to be the people reporter here
yeah yeah
you know well and yeah to be able to
like set that up and grow that business
to the point where he would immediately
be able to be like spider-man's
appearance
on times square the trailers for morbius
and
venom let there be carnage now i think
everybody was pretty shocked to see the
picture of spider-man on the wall
in the morbius trailer over the picture
it said murderer
implying that this could be tom holland
spider-man and the reason they're saying
murderer is because
of what mysterio has framed him for so
people probably think that spider-man
murdered mysterio however
the picture on the wall is of the sam
raimi spider-man costume
this further points to a connection of a
spider-verse
happening then in the venom 2 trailer we
see steven graham's character
reading a newspaper that is the daily
bugle with the exact
same logo that the daily bugle had in
the sam
raimi tobey mcguire films so this daily
bugle which is apparently the same one
already exists in another universe and
before people get started talking about
how
this venom universe could be the sam
raimi universe it's not we already had
an eddie brock and
venom in that universe they are clearly
different but this daily bugle
is the same which means there is some
multiverse stuff happening here
maybe because with the deal that sony
and marvel have they can't use tom hall
and spider-man to be specifically
featured so they gotta use
the ones from the one the ones they do
own yeah may i
definitely see that it could just be
that too yeah it's like if you're gonna
go off and do your own thing and not
have an actual spider-man around then
borrow from your old lore
i believe you i just think it's
important to at least
play devil's advocate once in a while
i i take it personal point number eight
tom holland that poor kid
he spoiled a lot for far from home and
other things as well
poor kids spoil anything for this
upcoming movie
multi-millionaire
then in another interview when he's not
specifically asked about the spider
verse he says
i know everything about the film so
clearly he is trying to we're really
talking about
this accept this one specifically spoil
the fact that it is happening in no way
home
point number 10 is that sony and disney
have recently reached a new deal with
each other
the sony spider-man films are finally
going to be on disney plus and when new
ones come out they will be on disney
plus as well
now what this shows us is that sony and
disney are playing
nice we were scared that before when
they were doing that renegotiation that
spider-man tom hall and spider-man might
not stay in the mcu
but unfortunately over a year ago they
came to a new agreement and it looks
like now they're still playing really
nice with each other
this means that both parties must think
that spider-man no way home is going to
be an
insanely good film and if the
spider-verse is involved of course it is
there's really no way it could fail
even if it's not as good as homecoming
or far from home the fact that it has
the spider-verse in it is going to make
it one of the biggest movies of all time
and with reports stating that andrew and
toby might not actually be done
after this movie it would make sense
that sony and disney would want to
extend their agreement and contracts see
the thing is though
i think he has a point because the move
can the movie suck
of course there's a possibility the
movie can suck however i feel like the
odds of that
being the reception are so slim
because the nostalgia and excitement
if all this does happen and play out and
we see it on screen
if it's a crappy film there could be
such an emotional manipulation of the
audience
to have you thinking this is the
greatest spider-man event
in history because you're overcome by
the possibility that all these worlds
characters exactly live action
franchises would cross stunt doubles
tagging each other on
instagram we have had many reportings of
andrew garfield's stunt double being
spotted on the set
of no way home while posting a video one
day that was seemingly on the set of no
way home he
actually tagged toby mcguire in another
post he tagged tom holland stunt double
now there's really only one reason why
all three
of the spider-man stunt doubles will be
together and that is of course to film
for their respective spider-man
and this one offers a lot of validation
for the fact that there are going to be
three spider-man
in the film point number 12. one of the
crew members
a lot of evidence that
one included a shirt that had andrew
garfield spider-man on it with other
parts that were hidden
probably hiding other spider-man i mean
spider-man
no way home shirt with andrew garfield
spider-man on it
well there's really only one explanation
for that andrew garfield spider-man is
in the movie no of course what that
sting of the hill and i'm not too sure
how accurate this is but i heard
rumblings that that crew member could
have gotten fired who knows that is a
pretty big leak then we have number 13.
i mean don't make the [ __ ] shirt get
until you're done
don't make the shirt i feel like i'm
ridiculous as
awesome as it is to be on that groove to
have that shirt
at the same time if i was the production
team i would be like let's hold on to
these till the film has been released
because of special circumstances like
this
[Music]
so my soul dies a little more the
closest your soul dies i know you're so
dying
to live with it then we have number 13
which i briefly talked about before
we have willem dafoe's green goblin
talked about
in just a ton of different reports and
leaks
based off of everything we know right
now willem dafoe's green goblin from the
sam raimi universe
is going to be the main villain i mean
why not alfred molina's
doc akkas coming in jamie foxx's elektra
was coming and we have a bunch of other
villains reportedly coming as well
so if we have two people alfredo and
willem dafoe
coming from the sam raimi universe it
would make sense that toby maguire
spider-man comes
and lastly you know what's great is that
the villains of spider-man 1 and 2 from
toby maguire are
fantastic villains and we will finally
be able to see that i 100
believe i mean undoubtedly all from
molina's in it
like way more than i believe the
spider-man are in it actually it's
exciting to be like oh we're finally
gonna see them like
hang out with each other yeah and like
interact and consort and scheme and
they're two
great actors on top of that you know
absolutely that's cool point number
fourteen
is the overall direction that everything
is heading towards
literally almost everything that we know
if not
everything that we know about something
like home points to it being a
multiverse
spider-verse film i mean even the title
no way home could be about
no way back to his original universe now
of course we think it's going to be
because he's going to be on the run
as a fugitive after being framed for the
murder of mysterio
but it could be about either him or
other characters not being able to get
back home
every leak that we've had every major
report from a major trade company has
all said that this is going to be a
spider-verse
film at this point if it's not a
spider-verse film and
all of these things are wrong i'm going
to be in absolute
shock and i think that everybody else is
going to be as well
but let me know what you think is this
enough evidence to basically confirm the
spider verse in no way home
or do you think that all of this is
either simply coincidence or
intentional misdirect from marvel
studios let me know what you think down
below
everyone they need to learn how to
misdirect in a way that doesn't
make people furious instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof i'm excited for this man
absolutely i think if they're not in it
it would behoove them to
release a statement at a certain point i
mean they had to deal with the one
division
imagine what this would be this would be
cataclysmically
way worse of a situation yeah absolutely
and
would it be marvel's fault it wouldn't
be i just think it would help them
if they were like if they're really not
in it just be like
they're not educated i feel like if that
was the case they would have had to have
come out at this point because it is
such a it's over shouting yeah
overshadowing everything such a runaway
train
of information speculation and
excitement that if it
really wasn't yeah i think at this point
with what they've learned from actors
experience
even with the paul benny thing like uh
yeah
to come out and set people's
expectations the right way
okay yeah that's cool okay we're
wrapping up guys subscribe to cause
wonder if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
niraj krishnan to me you are indian
peter parker whenever i think of one of
these spider-man videos for some reason
i just imagine
you you're do you really yeah yeah you
imagine roger
looking out over the city and uh he's a
cultured guy but he's also kind of an
unassuming guy and i feel like
to find this every time they could uh
you know doing the spider verse if they
could have like the bollywood spider-man
come in you want to play him
you know absolutely definitely it would
be a good thing that everyone would love
because if there's one thing spider-man
films have proven it's that musical
numbers and peter parker go together so
who to bring that to life but but better
than you
thanks i love you
you